welcome to this video playing exactly
the same player again this is fun it
doesn't happen so often that you that
you have a director rematch in the
five-minute pool but here we go yeah
there are many many lines here I go for
another favorite of mine 97 some maybe
not the best possible line but I always
had a soft spot for that so let's let's
try that again this is one of the better
lines for white against it now c4c form
yeah okay this is not not bad at all
Bishop d3 mmm how is it played I really
forgot it there should be seven I think
the point of blacks play in general is
okay he grabbed the pawn f4 is protected
by the night and you're ready to jump to
e3 return it but in the process you
gained the bishops which is nice and you
have free play or black's pieces are
able to develop to normal squares this
has some advantage of being easier to
play compared to too many g five lines
g5 is the very principle move on move
three may be the best one even but it
always takes at least in me it takes me
yeah some time and effort to understand
what's going on so am I very often
prefer one of those less committal
approaches just getting a normal
position and not trying to refute the
King's gambit it's probably not possible
anyway maybe there are ways to to get a
better position
then I have at the moment but certainly
no way to completely kill the opening ok
I'm playing as some as described the
only thing is it takes lots of time if
it takes now and in place rocky one not
sure how healthy this is for me he's
taking some time interesting we thought
that ok didn't take I thought you would
just take and play with 81 ok anyway
what now is going to take here and take
with the rook at the end probably I'd
like to play c5 really attack the center
yeah come on let's do that it's a bit
risky because of my really a somewhat
mediocre development but it's not it's
not so great if I just let him have this
some extra central pawn that the moment
c5 at least seems technically feasible
ok I wonder what d5 ok didn't did go for
that I take now and I takes I have 95
which should be yeah there should be ok
at least I'm as as mentioned I'm behind
in development but I have a very nice
diagonal after the caption seen on ok I
think it must take or does he have some
technical shot you know I think he must
take Bishop takes and then i have the
bishop here on a very strong diagonal
yeah this looks okay I think I'm taking
only three andrew ke one really was was
a lot stronger this looks like i have i
have two bishops and not clear what he
has he's got them yeah does he have
something on age seven rook some really
drastic attack me i don't i don't really
think so he needs to attend to this
diagonal
hmm yeah I mean I'm really the last
person to to to to criticize some other
guys time management but he's really
slow even slower than I am okay watch
now mm figure Bishop g5 probably playing
but should be to where it does not help
hmm i'd like to to keep the bishops of
course not take on d4 for example this
is a bit too too lame Queen B 6 yeah
it's also not great a move like Queen g5
that's Rock g3 this does not help
oh ji-ho Bishop b2 maybe maybe some
after that Bishop g5 then maybe but
Quinn chief the rookie 3m does not help
hmm I don't don't really see a great
move here ok let's try to get stuff
exchanged him if he goes rook f3f bishop
e6 I can take on d4 with the check and
then bishop is six ok so I think he
probably needs to take after which I may
be able to enter only three something
like that now maybe maybe this was was
ok i'm not i'm not sure i didn't want to
spend even more time to spoil this time
advantage I'm glad that I'm playing a
bit cookie at the moment so I actually
have some action on the clock yeah isn't
he almost forced to take I but I'm a bit
no he is not force take shape g4 here
maybe come on let's not think too long
attacking the rook and where is it going
to go rook d to this Queen g5 and
there's a lot lots of stuff hanging ok
well now I could take here but f7 hangs
I have Bishop e6 with the temple because
of the pin I don't want to play with
your basic wait this is a system that
take on d4 is taking here but is this
more than a check really though is just
a check with him that's not so dangerous
I'm having this this excellent pin at
the end not sure that taking on f7
really am Jack it's so great for him I
can take now I think utilizing the pin
okay I'd love to play ruge f8 but it's
it's just check made unfortunately hmm
it should be too maybe he has no check
if I go Bishop e2 where is he going to
go hmm you should have five baby Bishop
f5 a ditch this is at least so so
irritating that he probably losses on
time and it's also a good movie I'm
check winning winning winning material
look up white forfeits on time yeah
Bishop f5 was strong I guess you know I
think that the whole the whole critical
point is here I think he must take and
play rook e1 Gammons also the computer
suggestion this is much more in spirit
of the position getting this with the a
rook and then all pieces are in play
it's yeah it's not clear on this
position something like that for example
is is a playable option for black
completing development
say something something like that this
is fairly typical for this this line y
term is maybe a bit better it's nothing
nothing too too scary though I have fun
I have the bishops and and decent
development yeah this is not not really
so harmonious and then comparison yeah
c5 ambitious but it worked out it worked
out fine takes and here I thought you
must take with the pawn and yeah well
after that this felt like like a good
position to me but maybe the the
development problems on I really a
serious compounds to go here which makes
some sense of course attacking f7 John I
cannot I cannot do this I mean I can but
it's very very risky is playing look to
you one Queen somewhere and now I'm so
far behind in development that it might
cost me so bad bad a lot better not gab
Bishop c4 is a good idea play that one
dumb rookie hm it's probably not not too
bad and this is a good news and here we
should be success also not bad okay I
don't think this is too too terrible
yeah it's about equal check the comp
gives it a sequel ok and now Queen f2 is
the move that keeps the position
together yeah the point being that
rookie fries of course running into into
a mate checkmate da while he played
Queen f1 and this there should be two
was a good reply but not winning and
Bishop f5
about that oh yeah this is not as a
mistake interesting now I didn't see
that at all this one hmm yeah well yeah
hey does singing so Bishop f5 is a
mistake surprisingly I thought this was
this was a cute move no yeah the rook is
saying this is the problem I was
thinking okay cannot take it because
Queen check cannot move the bishop but
at the end this is saying so um this
would have would have won the game maybe
for white or at least at least it's a
it's a very very healthy pawn Oh amazing
Earth completely overlooked that I mean
I relaxed a bit because of the time but
still this is a big mistake there should
be two was better you know i briefly
considered that but not clear what my
next move was him it's according to the
comp it's not winning it looks like
there should be something but it seems
there isn't curious alright thanks for
watching